i'm here with dr maha devin who's an er
physician at stanford and and what are
what are we looking here looking at here
well what we're going to do is look at
some radiographs of the cervical spine
or of your neck uh and try to determine
whether they're adequate or not and an
attic what does it mean to be adequate
when you have an adequate view you can
see from the first vertebra all the way
down to the the junction of the seventh
cervical vertebra and the first thoracic
vertebra i see and and we call it
adequate because it means it's adequate
to make a diagnosis exactly you want to
be able to see the entire cervical spine
so you can make sure that there's not an
injury there cool cool and so what are
what are we looking at over here what
are we directly sterilizing uh so what
we're looking at is uh the lateral which
shows essentially part of the cervical
spine shows cervical vertebrae one
through five i see so this is just to
make myself clear orient so the
these are both lateral x-rays and we say
lateral it was actually from the side
exactly of the person and uh this shows
how well i know my anatomy this this
person on this actually they're facing
this way uh they're actually facing the
other way look at that oh i can see
there's a little jaw okay no i was just
i was just testing you
good good job all right so the person is
facing that way that this way this way
is the front and you were just showing
your tel you were kind of counting the
different um the the different bones
exactly you were saying this is one
that's one two two three
four
five and that's why you you hear people
sometimes with back injuries saying you
have a problem in what they call it in
like this l5 l5 right yeah that's what
they're talking about like that okay so
sorry and and actually we count even uh
further forward from there um and we
look exactly at those things that look
kind of look like squares those are the
actual vertebra exactly right there
exactly and although we're interested in
the entire spine when we can't we kind
of go down and as you can see if you
look at the fifth square there below
that um it's really hard to see the
squares of six and seven right we can't
see anything below that it looks like
was this person's shoulder is blocking
it exactly you can see that that big
white thing there is the shoulder that's
gotten in the way and it's making it
hard to see they shouldn't have worn
those lead shoulder pads
sorry
and and it's making hard to see whether
there's something going on down there
right now so it's really a mystery as
you've shown so how do you how do you
solve it how do you solve this problem
if you look over at the other film it's
what we call a swimmer's view and what
we've asked the patient to do is
raise one arm up and lower the other and
in doing so you could kind of clear that
lower cervical spine and allow better
visualization of the entire spine i see
and you're taking it from the direction
of the raised arm uh on the side of the
take you take from the side and you can
see this is the raised arm right over
here exactly that's the raised arm
exactly against the shoulder and the
other arm on the further side of the
patient is down
and that's what allows us to get i guess
get the shoulder position so it doesn't
block like it does in this left exactly
exactly i see and over here and over
here it is much clearer that this person
is also facing in this direction
and and okay so let me see if so we can
count this is this is number one right
up here that's one one two
three
four
five
six and yeah look we already got to six
we didn't see six over here and then we
got seven exactly okay okay and so you
would call this an adequate view for
what we're trying the of the neck
because now we can look at all the way
through seven absolutely we can get all
the way down to seven and ideally you
wanna see the top of one which comes
actually in this counting system we go
one through seven and then we start back
at one again because we're starting with
the thoracic vertebra so oh number one
it's like yeah it's like when those
streets where they re start numbering i
can't find that all right so it becomes
one again exactly is that did i number
that right you did and again we're
looking more to the front you're you've
got your numbers perfectly on every
spinous process a little bump that you
can feel if you press on the back of
your neck right but what we're really
interested is the alignment of the front
of the vertebral body this is one this
is two
three four five six
seven you want to look at the top of one
where's the top of one uh if you if you
just continue down right there there and
it's sometimes it's difficult to see but
exactly you wanna see that there's an
alignment right in front of okay
there's something here that i can't
really see exactly but you're an expert
so maybe you see things like that
all right all right so okay so not now
what do we do with this now uh so we've
shown you that you can get a swimmer's
view and it can show you all the way
down to c7 t1 but on the original view
as you've shown there we can't see that
so what we did for this patient was get
a swimmer's view i see and so this is
adequate and we have this other we have
this other slide right over here
we have this other one right over here
and why is why is this one interesting
uh this is the same patient and now
we've done we've taken that same view
that we talked about before the swimmers
view where this is the same patient as
th this patient right not not this
patient over here exactly exactly that
one looked overall pretty healthy that
was a that was a normal swimmer's view
but here is an abnormal swimmer's view
and the same person same person as this
one not the not the other facing in the
same direction in case you want to test
it yes okay good good and if you count
again
starting with the first okay vertebrates
want to go one two
this is three right here three's this
one right here
three oh it's a kind of a
oh i see it's kind of a this whole thing
is three that whole thing is three right
there exactly
four
five
six
and then seven it looks
like right around there if i'm reading
that if i see that probably it's a
little darker
and the key important finding there is
that as you draw a line along the
anterior or the front of all those
vertebral bodies if you were to connect
them right just like that if i can i'll
draw a dotted line okay
fantastic it looks pretty all right and
as you go down oh look at that seven
looks like a
a little disruption there exactly and
and it's pushed back and the problem is
right behind those bones is your spinal
cord wow and so any kind of injury like
this potentially could injure your
spinal cord and lead to permanent
paralysis and weakness so this is the
main thing i guess there's there's two
big takeaways at least from this little
short segment that we've said is that
one is you got to make sure that you
have the information to make a diagnosis
on so for example this right over here
you couldn't even do something useful
because you're not able to see the
number six and number seven exactly we
would call it inadequate and we would
say we can't draw any firm conclusions
from that that's why you want to get in
that swimmer's position raise the arm
from the direction that you're looking
at correct and they'll lower the other
arm and then you can see something like
this and this would this right over here
is cause for trouble because now you can
go all the way down to seven and you can
actually see that they're not aligned
absolutely and so this is someone you
wouldn't let get out of your emergency
department without seeing a specialist a
spine specialist whereas if you didn't
have that view you might be falsely
reassured that everything was okay when
in fact there's a serious problem there
wow very cool very cool thanks a bunch
thank you